these jeans from Japan that I forget
what they call blue something but
they're the best denim comes from Japan
and they deep diam something goes so do
you know what to do with these he gets
my house this is that yes yours do you
know what to do with these are you no no
they're a little big yes that's that's
how they're supposed to be I swear to
god he's dead serious
yes so what you do you put them on you
put them on and because you wanted to
fit tight you want to fit perfect and
have like that selvage look you wear
them into the ocean so just put them on
go in the ocean and just kind of swim
maybe do some squats and I went are you
[ __ ] me right now he goes no that's
for the best fit on it well that's never
happening I'm not going to ever he goes
do you want the best fit or not you'll
if that's what it takes no I'm not
here's alright well let's just fill up
your bathtub with saltwater what no
we're not doing that I don't want
something weird would you wash them
afterwards yes so you this salt doesn't
fit yeah and the salt and whatever just
you want like that that grind is so
interesting all jeans start off like
this dark yeah and then they go light
these are darker than those what about
dark dark where I'm in the ocean you
just want to roll around the sand and
get it all kind of in there it well I'm
not that's not
I'm never know you know that'd be a
nightmare getting back to the house what
are you doing it I got a um I got a
thing I got to do I have to go to the
Tesla dealership and then I got to go
wear jeans into the ocean and roll
around the sand so I get the perfect do
we get you have your like jump to a pool
and jeans or anything they get no they
get heavy so heavy
no you're drown oh wait around yeah I'm
walking to Blue Bottle coffee and I'm
with my buddy Joey and I see eight
fifteen hundred dollars worth of caviar
yesterday cool and I back to this I
didn't pay for it I walk alone my buddy
Joe and I look I see this guy was 6-3
about 235 blond and he and I and I look
at his shorts he's got shorts the kind
of Schwartz I wear on the Goldbergs sure
- right but more expensive and designer
and I went and I stopped and I went well
look at that guy's legs
yeah it's the craziest things I've ever
seen in my life yeah the craziest legs
I've ever seen sure go what does that
guy do and you know your boy I walk I'm
gonna go bro okay let's take your dick
what do you do for your legs because I
played it I was that well
you know I'm a Viking I guess and when I
started lifting weights my body just
took to it I go what were you an athlete
he goes I played a Texas AI ma'am I was
a tight end and he behind Marcus Bennett
yeah he said so I only played my senior
year he goes yeah it was bad Marcus
Bennett so I sat the bench but then I
play my senior a really cool guy
after trades people at Barry's boot camp
see if you can see Barry's bootcamp
Venice there's a ton of Barry's boot
camps right now is that a good if you
you've done that right I've never done
Barry's I've heard of it I've never done
it though I like orange thery I've never
done Barry's though I'm sure it's good I
would be down to do it
how about berries I was looking for a
picture of this dude I'm bearish yeah I
was laughing I was like well I'm did you
get a picture or something you bring it
up here fellas
I'm no I'm trying to find his name but
whatever yeah good-looking dude yeah
well I was just it was very humorous to
me because he was he was so striking
that everyone in the coffee shop was
looking at him or just you well there is
one other one there he is there he is
terrible picture Robbie you're kidding
terrible picture of him you're kidding
that's a terrible picture of a terrible
picture on the right is that really
that's him oh hey Bryan Hey look at me
and Ruki yeah hold on let me talk to you
you're gonna meet him and you're gonna
shut it up let me just talk to you yeah
don't care wait on your fear what you
say about my boyfriend cuz I used to be
straight I'm no longer spray no I know
you're not okay I want you to come out
the age of 52 as a gay man I'm not doing
that unless Dan drew and this Android's
says there's my - impressive about this
guy Bobby's a little twist me Baba
please he's ever bit as big as you you
have to understand his legs are bigger
than yours his legs scoff at yours hey
let me tell you this his legs hey you
don't know you're a gay older man dude
I'm just telling you hey have you out of
the office we've ever done
have I ever chin can I ever came in here
and told us regularly Google no please
don't
about a story about a man that I saw in
a coffee shop that's the point I good he
was I stopped him as a I stopped
you got I go I go I stopped him and I
was like it was so gay of me and you
would have been so you would have been
rolling I would much more eat him up I
need better picture listo do it do it
right now you need to calm down because
this is gonna be what we gonna do we're
gonna see this guy go cool Brian good
lookin dude you saw the copy function
talk to him by the pictures bad picture
bad picture I can't tell well there is
pictures not good pictures looking for
the dude bright ran to the coffee shop
there you go the instructors I gotta go
take some classes the point I'm making
well hey wow I gotta talk to him Wow I
know I would just have a talk with
yourself about about my about my gayness
about my terrible game in heaven are you
homophobic dude no I'm not I just find
it crazy you just told me a story about
this dude you ran to a car I told ya
because listen ask him if it's a
ridiculous hot girl Bri tomorrow even my
buddy do I enjoy it with my buddy chosen
are you gonna ask him about his like
psycho I am I don't get it I just I
don't understand I'm spilt there cuz I
want I don't different I mean not into
men it's so clarity I want to be I want
to be I want to look like that now I
sure I get it here's the thing donut
shop bet a million dollars that a dick
has never touched Brian's mouth I could
not make that gone to your head cut your
head and do it for two guys I'd like
Neverland oh let's not
he's too into dude this I don't know
what you're talking about but it's not a
big deal bro not you obviously it is and
obviously you're ridiculing me just
because I appreciate masculine
pulchritude let's go to current events I
don't I guess I guess you want to talk
about boyfriend at bears but so Louie CK
is back in the news for a set that he
did at the San Jose improv you see I
feel is he trying now this is just his
thing like he wants to he's always been
this kind of now it's out there right
he's always been 112 but he's always
said [ __ ] that was ages oh yeah so it's
not surprising also that's that's that I
get that joke I like to jerk off and I
don't like being alone
they probably cry probably crush and I'm
sorry it's a good joke it's funny I mean
I'm gonna tell me and Rogin retirement
when he decides just to go out and start
doing theaters they'll be lines around
the block use me kill sell no he's
bigger than that because this is what
happens right right when when everyone
goes when the people who are this me to
movement all those people are so loud on
Twitter social media try to take away
that everything that louis ck's worked
for and they go here's the enemy [ __ ]
this guy the rest of and that's the
majority the rest of the United States
and his fans and just conf and general
go you know what when I can stand for
this we're gonna support Louie CK now
you get this ain't fair what you guys
doing to here yeah he's paid for it yeah
this isn't this [ __ ] up we're gonna
let you bully him what you guys trying
to do so guess what happens his ticket
sales go that's right
through the roof that's right because
you've been out there NPR NPR daddies
National Public Radio it's a very
liberal place these people who don't go
to comedy clubs and who were you know
very sort of like very judgmental and
stuff and they were like oh he'll never
come back from this I think I'll have to
go to Europe and try to scratch together
a career no I'm not listening to this
gon don't know you guys don't know what
the [ __ ] you just know they were so out
of titled regular people the way you
people let us go what the [ __ ] that is
right these are liberal journalists
don't like people like yeah you made
some mistake you didn't hit any women
right you know woman beater you know
break anybody
those are unforgivable actions yeah what
he did he paid for it yeah now he's a
comic like you oh he's been and we do
make this distinction and even when and
you know Americans are pretty forgiving
like for example you hit women and
usually you're in some big trouble but
unless you're gay I was gonna say like
Greg Hardy who was I think convicted
wasn't here or has had three different
situations that concern domestic
violence and you said Sonia Singh when
he need when he need because you went
hard in the paint on this guy correct
super hard this morning on my show and
when he need what's his name and
in the head you went that's the
equivalent of Mike Tyson biting
somebody's here it's a way out it was a
way out because he got tired and he
didn't have the goods and he was he was
gonna start to lose he's a bad guy that
guy who cares backup or character
por hora Balearic tur can't can't paint
the zebra stripes zebra bad zebra
yeah bad till we try painting black yeah
and it should not gonna work he's a
zebra bad zebra just be zebra the
hilarious joke when Jessica Simpson had
a hair stylist flown in I talked to him
I said she flew you in from New York he
goes yeah I said you're the best time he
goes oh I don't know and I said and
somebody goes he's the best I said why
she's well he'll make her hair a certain
kind of blond that you won't know why
but it stands out it just is better than
everybody else there's a guy who were
worked out a boxing ring with Tony and
he's the number one male hairdresser in
the United States but he's not from here
for your Ease from and great guy looks
identical to Tom Brady he's married to a
famous actress I forget his name great
dude I think he's French
hmm and Tony was telling me how much
charge for hair come like what the [ __ ]
he owes well no he works with everybody
yeah probably just yeah those guys I
take my I'll take my half and I'll see
him I just like wait am I here just I
want to see him be like dude no you
should do this it's details it's the
[ __ ] details who cuts your hair cuz
the school name Colleen do you been
going there for a while yeah ever since
I've been in LA I met her through the
girl who used to dye my hair they're
tough to find right like again yes sir
the [ __ ] your [ __ ] I there's a guy was
super super expensive that my wife is
trying to get me to go to like $4 like a
used to go to off Main Street yeah
they're not mean a bikini a bikini yeah
yeah it looked like you blew it
yeah $500 that's right you always look
exactly the a but I never chart paid
that much but no I'm just saying like
that if you paid anything well this
guy's charged for Nauticus come and see
me and he was working on a show I was
doing and I went what would you do with
my hair and goes magic Oh what's gonna
happen dude I'm gonna lie
you're gonna go Brys what if he did nice
you're really good-looking do you know
the way the way I do it I go to the
Lincoln barber's off Lincoln and clearly
and it's all Mexican dudes in there
right yeah and when you go in there it's
a crapshoot because you just walk in
there's 18 [ __ ] barbers my boy but
there's this new dude he came from New
York he's this Porto Rican dude long
here speaks zero English really zero and
he is the [ __ ] man I've only worked
with him twice hmm and I saw he was
working with some day I'm like god I
hope he [ __ ] gets finished with that
guy starting jumping with him
then there's the girl who no offense
probably the worst I'm like don't give
me her you can't insult them right now
I'm good you should go is that all they
do is go next there's no no appointment
nothing next and so it's our race and
I'm sweating and the Puerto Rican goes
hmm
because like this thing I was like [ __ ]
yeah bro [ __ ] right well I feel like
you have something that hard to cut
right did well she doesn't understand
English shot that song come over and
translate it for him it's not that hard
they have to fade it's all about the
fade it's an art bro I can fade your
hair up Oh
Terry's baby sadder would like older
man's age it's like whoa my problem like
a complete [ __ ] dude all of that problem
all of that as you get older is like
getting fades dressing a little too cool
and even TRT as far as I'm concerned
there I said it when you see my back
ripple and I pull myself up like a champ
like a champ 30 times while talking to
you
why wouldn't I give that to you as it's
a gif it's a gift it's a gift